Oh, I'm getting overwhelmed.
I can't start crying
before the movie starts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CO-HOST: The world premiere
of Marvel Studios' Eternals
was epic.
And if you missed
a moment of it,
don't worry, because you
can catch it all right here,
presented by Lexus.
CO-HOST: We are
live in Hollywood.
That's the biggest
carpet I've been on.
Gilgamesh.
I like to call him the
revolutionary evolutionary.
CO-HOST: Speak on it.
How do you prepare for a
role where you're shooting
cosmic beams out of your eyes?
Like, I don't know.
A lot of staring in the mirror
and practicing your laser eyes.
Did you do any
actual research on set,
maybe take some things home?
We won't tell
anybody, I promise.
We won't tell Kevin.
INTERPRETER: Oh,
what if I tell you?
No, no, no.
I can't tell you.
No.
We know you have a couple
brothers and a couple siblings,
what was their reaction
when you found out?
They didn't really think
I was going to get it.
I'm sure everybody says this
when they do a movie together,
but we really became a family.
[LAUGHTER]
MCU.
Anything can happen.
Well, there we go.
So yeah, it's going to be
a different relationship.
And--
They told me to
crash this party.
Oh, they told you?
Somebody told me
crash your party.
Who told you?
But how do you--
you know, with you
and Richard Madden,
how did you go about
creating this relationship
that spans thousands of years
and has that rich history?
We know how to push
each other's buttons.
We know how to make
each other laugh.
We can infuriate each other
as well at times, so kind of
like, yeah, an old married
couple in many ways.
Here we were, finishing
the Infinity saga,
and I was thinking, where
do we go from here, how do
we continue, where do we grow?
And Chloe came in and told us.
I'm in awe of that woman.
And it was exciting to
come to work every day
and just to watch her and
be a part of her mind,
because you become
a part of her mind.
Guys, look at the moon.
That's so beautiful.
Sorry.
You have no idea
how much I love her.
- Look at the moon, Victoria.
- How much I love this man.
- Look at at the moon.
- How much I love this--
You can't fly in real life?
Not in real life.
Don't tell my
nephews and my niece.
What was the hardest
part about keeping
everything secret?
Calling up all my
enemies and telling them
I'm in a Marvel movie.
I don't enemies.
CO-HOST: Look at me now.
Yeah.
It was really fun,
because I got to do
a lot of hand choreography.
I don't want to
give anything away.
get killed, but--
I know a bunch of stuff.
Guys, I know a lot of stuff.
I'm not joking.
I heard you say once that
this was kind of a coming of age
story for Sersi, which I think
is so interesting, because, you
know, 7,000 years old, you
think she's already here,
but talk to us a
little bit more about--
I know.
You'd have thought,
after 7,000 years,
she would have-- no, it
turns out there are still
some things for her to learn.
What I love about being
a part of this universe is
the diversity and the inclusion,
and so people can recognize
that people who look
like you are out here--
people who may be
different sizes,
who love differently, who are--
all are inclusive.
So it's really great to show
that anybody can be a hero.
Well, we want to ask
you more questions,
but clearly you only
know that you're
a guy who works in the museum.
A guy who works in the museum.
That's what I'm running with.
There's nothing
more to ask there.
Great.
That's what I'm running with.
I can't wait to see Dane
working in the museum.
That's what I came here for,
and that's what they did too.
Marvel Studios' Eternals will
be in theaters on November 5.
Tickets are available now.
You should do it right now.
And it's only in theaters--
only in theaters.
That's right.
Only in theaters.